salut soir malade alors le 24 juin 1991
madame marchal été retrouvée morte
poignardée barricadé de l'intérieur dans
la cave de sa villa la chamade à mougins
sur la porte on découvre en lettres de
sang l'inscription omar m'a tuer or vous
le jardinier de la même marshall vous
appelez justement omar vous êtes
inculpés d'homicide volontaire et
condamné à 18 ans de réclusion
partiellement gracié par le président de
la république vous sortirez de prison
après sept ans deux mois et huit jours
derrière les barreaux
mais le 20 novembre 2002 la cour de
cassation rejette votre demande en
révision
votre procès déclarant que les nouveaux
éléments présentés par votre défense
permettent pas de douter de votre
culpabilité
d'autre part l'avocat de la famille
marchal maître kiejman déclare je ne
suis pas étonné qu omar raddad soient
convaincus de n'avoir pas tué madame
marchal tant de gens le lui répète avec
complaisance
depuis si longtemps soutenir qu omar
haddad a été condamné et le reste parce
qu'il est marocain relève de la pure
démagogie dixit maître kiejman voit la
situation omar haddad gracié mais pas
innocenté donc quelque part toujours
coupable alors avec la collaboration de
sylvie lotir on vous avez écrit un livre
qui est publié au seuil et qui s'appelle
pourquoi moi
[Musique]
donc comme un rat date plusieurs livres
ont été publiés sur votre affaire mais
vous vous êtes dit personne ne peut
parler à ma place mieux que moi c'est
vrai pas mieux moi personne présenter
quelque chose ça alors le matin du 25
juin 1991 vous discutez avec latifa
votre épouse et sa soeur sur le balcon
de chez vous à toulon lorsque vous
remarqué sans vraiment y prêter
attention
des gendarmes en bas de l'immeuble
quelques minutes plus tard ont sonné à
la porte
il est 11h30 le table du déjeuner est
prête et le type 10s qu'omar raddad est
là et là vous pensez quoi
rien ce mariage tant à mourir en raison
de taper à la porte mais belle sur le
vrai la porte qu'on vous dit
le temps des secours sommes sur un
malade il est là le temps des moineaux
j'ai présenté il m'a discuter avec nous
j'ai dit oui mais pourquoi ça reste
comme ça pourquoi pourquoi après me dit
non on ne sait pas et le siège darmon
voilà donc au poste les gendarmes vous
dise pourquoi tu as tué madame marchal
vous comprenez pas il vous montre à ce
moment là une photo d'elle couverte de
sang et c'est comme ça en fait que vous
apprenez la mort de madame marchal
d'accord elles commenceraient après la
mort de madame ensuite vous détourner
les yeux et vous oblige à regarder une
autre photo celle de la porte de la cave
où est écrit avec du sang omar m'a tuer
vous savez pas bien lire et écrire le
français mais vous reconnaissez omar
parce que ça c'est votre prénom dont
vous savez l'écrire et vous comprenez à
ce moment là évidemment qu'on vous
accuse du meurtre de madame marchal
qu'est ce qui se passe dans votre tête à
ce moment là qu'est ce qui se passe
comme comme je retrouvais parce que déjà
chez nous au maroc est ce on est mort on
dirait pas
on ne bouge pas on mange pas et chez
vous alors évidemment dans les
interrogatoires qui vont suivre vous
êtes victime d'un gros handicap c'est
que vous connaissez mal le français
1 - bien que maintenant évidemment ce
qui permettait dites-vous aux gendarmes
d'écrire à peu près ce qu'il voulait
dans l'est dans les procès verbaux et
vous raconter dans votre bouquin que
quand vous parler arabe
le gendarme continue à taper à la
machine parce que cette époque là il ya
deux corées ya des questions je
comprends il ya beaucoup de questions je
comprends pas c'est pourquoi je demande
et interprète gendarmerie me refuse il
m'a dit on ne connaît votre perdre et
parle bien le français ça que mon père
et ça fait 41 morts en france ouais ça
fait commander chacun à sa place mon
père ce moment pour moi c'est moi vous
fait une confiance aveugle aux gendarmes
pour vous les gendarmes ils peuvent pas
mentir donc cette époque là ouais ouais
vraiment de donner aux jeunes est une
grande confiance c'est vrai jamais j'ai
pensé à ma caisse que les passagers
redoux et alors durant toutes ces
interrogatoires vous n'avez pas mais
vous dites que vous finissez par
comprendre pourquoi on peut avouer
parce que finalement on finit par se
dénoncer de crimes qu'on n'a pas commis
simplement pour pouvoir dormir manger et
elle est en paix elle est là et là vous
comprenez ce qui s'est passé avec
patrick dils fine siens après après
parce que je sais en a beaucoup des gens
posent la question patrick tesse
pourquoi elle reconnaît un crime n'est
pas fait pour moi je pose pas cette
question
oui parce que j'ai passés par là
n'importe qu'elle est capable d'ouvrir
n'importe quoi même les choses étaient
parfaites et capable de dire oui
dessinée tout comme ça te donne la paix
parce que tu es et stéphane tu es
fatigué t'es pas dormir est capable de
de raconter n'importe quoi comme c'est
triste quand vous êtes condamné donc à
18 ans vous ferez comme je les dix sept
en huit mois et 2 jours derrière les
barreaux
et vous dites quelqu'un qui est enfermé
pour rien dans une cellule de 9 mètres
carrés ne compte pas les jours mais des
seconds
ouais ouais parce que c'est là c'est la
raison pour laquelle le titre de mon
livre pourquoi moi ouais parce que c'est
c'est le seule phrase gdg passe beaucoup
dans ma tête et dans ma tête
pourquoi moi pourquoi je suis là qu'est
ce que j'ai fait c'est ça fait qu'on
pose beaucoup beaucoup de questions et
c'est vrai c'est pas on n'est pas les
genres et passe pas c'est la sécurité
passe pas cessé
c'est quelque chose tirer aujourd'hui
vous travaillez à marseille vous prenez
le train pour aller tous les matins
marseille à cette heure de toulon dans
une charcuterie halal dans votre combat
maintenant omar haddad et c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous avez écrit ce
livre avec sylvie le tir on vous voulez
que votre innocence soit reconnue et
vous dites si j'étais coupable
croyez vous que je voudrais un autre
procès oui parce qu'elle est quelque
chose moi je comprends pas son à cause
sans preuve
il est désolé on est tous coupables qui
a tué madame marché allemand a d'elle
quel type de marché sur les questions et
des milliers de personnes âgées pour
cette question kate et madame marchand
malheureusement moi mes avocats
la presse et sont pas droit d'arrêter le
coupable sauf la justice est notre
moteur arrêté le combat comme vous savez
dans la phrase de ses marques
omar m'a tuer il ya deux traces
génétique toutes les zones différentes
on a trouvé dans l'eau sa roue ses
marques et omar m'a tuer j'ai précise
quelque chose parce qu'il y en a sa
trace des liens c'est pas trouver
n'importe quoi droit de la porte s'est
trouvée ou ses marques et aux marques
peinture dans la salle ça veut dire
aujourd'hui pour moi je vous sur
certains c'est la personne
elle a écrit si lui-même et l'a tué
madame marche pourquoi la famille
marchal a choisi pour s'attaquer à un
jardinier marocain sont beaucoup de de
pouvoir visons maître leclerc qui est
quand même le président de la ligue des
droits de l'homme
c'est la question que je pose moi même
parce que d'autres départs
c'est vrai rien avocat le père des
droits de l'homme et après une dernière
fois la 1c milices la justice oui de
départ ils ont tout fait pour rien a pas
un deuxième procès mais aujourd'hui je
pose la question à tout le monde surtout
à la famille de la victime s qui sommes
satisfaits la personne est l'atout hier
madame marchal comme ça
esquissons cet esprit pour s'attarder
présent ça serait pas mis la question et
si un deuxième procès qui s'y prend le
risque
personne ne prend le risque c'est moi
d'y retourner au tournoi qui tire
pourquoi lorsque vous avez écopé de 18
ans de prison ce qui est beaucoup mais
ce qui pour un meurtre est moins que la
réclusion à perpétuité
pourquoi la famille de madame marchal
n'a pas protesté
c'est la question que pose moi même
parce que aujourd'hui le combat est
contre lui pour moi pour ma famille et
aussi pour madame marchal parce que
personne ne mérite de mourir comme ça et
aussi perso les mérites 18 ha parce que
je dédie souhaitable parce que c'est
grâce à l'opinion publique
c'est grâce à sa majesté hassan ii m
sera question pourquoi les enquêteurs
n'ont ils jamais interroger votre oncle
mimoun qui était le majordome de madame
marchal pendant des années parce qu'elle
est moins épais et l'après
mort de madame marchal et la demande est
d'avoir le jauge personnes les côtés
après cinq ans et l'a déclaré qu'est-ce
qui est madame marchal et le dira mais -
et la dire à la presse raconter ça à la
presse après la justice et les
interroger à nîmes ou là des paroles
qu'est ce qu'elle a dit à la presse le
dire à la justice après la justice et la
dct mois trop tard 1
mes skis et la justice et ça bien mais
moins que le travail est plus de satin
chez madame marchal et ça bien alors
pourquoi on pose pas la question
omar haddad
est-ce que vous avez été victime d'une
machination oui est ce que vous savez
qui a monté cette machination
non
[Musique]
vous savez pas où vous voulez pas le
dire intégrité je sais pas il faut pas à
causer je peux pas faire allégeance
je peux accuser quelqu'un sans preuve
comme on m'a fait moi je moi je ne fais
pas ça vous ne rallume
bravo merci merci beaucoup
savez pourquoi moi
et aux éditions du seuil
les corrections de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous mettez un
pouce bleus